When I was in high school, this interesting thing happened where I made a decision...
...that I was forever gonna do exactly what it is that I want with my life...
...which is creativity, painting, drawing, sculpting, building, making.
I don't consider myself a street artist.
I consider myself a fine artist that likes to dabble in the street.
I mean, ever since I was a little kid, I was in love with Buzz Lightyear.
And then when I grew up, I kind of just made him a metaphor to me.
You have the hand of God embracing what Buzz means to me.
So in my eyes, it just kind of a symbol for doing things...
...that others think aren't possible at the time.
Yeah, I'm just kind of treating life as a playground...
...and waking up and doing everything that I want to do every day.